before i tell you the story could we
just
enjoy this thing of beauty here the
mashed potatoes i don't know if that's
dill or rosemary clementi's dad says
it's rosemary so i'll go with that
the gravy the goat tony says it's the
gravy that goes with the turkey
the salad over there with the apples
good lord i can't wait
for somebody to invite me to dinner here
we go as a pandemic forces many families
to downsize their thanksgiving plans one
highly sought after item on the menu is
running very low this year there is a
shortage of small turkeys you saw
janet shamley standing there holding one
she shows us how the declining demand
for bigger birds is seriously affecting
some of the country's 2500 turkey
producers
so what'd she do she visited a family
farm in texas
the free-range turkeys raised by angela
smith and her son colby
sell out every thanksgiving there's
usually a waiting list
for their fresh birds in a normal
thanksgiving what's demand like for you
in terms of the size of turkeys people
want
18 to 20 is our normal normal
thanksgiving 18 to 20 all day
it feeds you know six eight people 10
people pretty darn good you know but
this year
most of these turkeys are too big for a
downsized holiday
at smith and smith farms they're still
getting inquiries but not for any toms
and hens
this size another customer asking for a
10 pound turkey
something colby wishes he could sell
them they're live animals they grow just
like me
and you i mean you can't put the pause
button on it and say hey you know
you're stopping at eight pounds sorry
buddy you know for a small family farm
like this where margins are razor thin
it's devastating the cost of buying the
chicks their feed
and processing won't cover what they
earn this turkey is a good example of
the size people are looking for this
year
right now it weighs about 13 pounds when
it gets to the table
it will weigh about 10. some won't buy a
turkey at all this year i'm only going
to get a turkey breast
because i'm the only one that likes
turkey in my
immediate family kathleen sheena's
thanksgiving has shrunk from 12 people
to four
saigon taylor is skipping a big
gathering to spend the holiday
only with his husband no matter what i
cook it's going to rock so
i got this and the leonard family
instead of one big thanksgiving there's
going to be four
smaller thanksgivings grosser stu
leonard junior is making big changes at
home
and in his seven stores in connecticut
new york and new jersey
we've ordered 20 percent less of the big
turkeys
and we've ordered 20 percent more of the
smaller turkeys
because we feel thanksgiving is going to
be smaller
butterball which typically sells a third
of all thanksgiving turkeys
ramped up production of smaller items
like boneless turkey roast
come on producers like the smiths are
adapting as well
selling turkey breasts and legs they
never
imagined the holiday would turn out like
this and we just kept hoping things
would change
that it would get better with a coveted
situation and
people would could be together but as we
see it's really not
turned out that way with potentially
lots of leftovers if customers who
reserve turkeys at farmers markets don't
show up to buy them
will it be a feast at the smith home i
know it's herky you're gonna laugh
we don't eat turkey on thanksgiving
after the rush of delivering turkeys
they say they don't have time to cook
one
meaning these gobblers might get the
ultimate holiday
a dinner table pardon it's almost
thanksgiving
for cbs this morning janet chamlion
burlington texas
turkey is